yes Hans Gustav Jung Grand professor in
infectious diseases why is this prize
the nobel prize in physiology or
medicine 2011 gone to these three
gentlemen well they have in common that
they will have done fantastic
discoveries discoveries regarding the
activation of the immune system and
those were the most the most excellent
you could find this year absolutely we
are certainly confident that these are
three absolutely outstanding candidates
for a price the immune system of course
is working here and now for all of us
for you and for me and luckily it
usually works so we don't get different
bacterial viruses but how does it work
well the music cells in the body have
sensors for foreign microorganisms those
sensors can be recognized by
microorganisms to the prize winners here
Hoffman and boiler discovered what those
sensors are then in order to kick on a
strong immune response we need to
activate what we call the adaptive
immune defense and the run Steinman
discovered really what kicked on that
active immune response it's via
interactions with so called dendritic
cells so we have sort of two lines of
defense system when it comes to
defendants about what you talk did you
already present a presentation being a
very dangerous world certainly we have
two lines we have a first immediate line
that protects us and actually clears us
from most pathogens but sometimes
pathogens can invade our body and we
need to mobilize a stronger defense
that's the second defense so this is a
really evolution at work i mean the the
bacteria's are trying to get the round
or in new system and immune system is
trying to work against them exactly that
is what it is and you mention the word
evolution it's amazing that we have kept
our a new system for more than 600
million years Hoffman discovered they
your system it flies amazingly the same
type of system operates in us in you and
me yeah got it that is the same gene
actually that works in in fruit flies
and in US and yes it's a it's a it's a
very similar gene which indeed to us
means that something is important if
something is conserved throughout
evolution it's probably very important
so it's easy to understand why they have
got the price i mean the immune system
is life supporting for all of us but
sometimes it works the wrong way and
then it can cause it's a lot of the very
common diseases it does indeed and this
is a problem first of all in some humans
some individual stimulus system does not
work those get more infections than
other people but if the bob is a bubble
children yes that's the most extreme
part and then there are situations where
the immune system overreacts and what is
dangerous is when the new system starts
to react against our own tissues our own
body is like a friendly fire in wall
it's tall shooting your own cells yes
you could say so what happens done well
kill diseases are we talking about them
well the new systems primary role is to
protect us against infectious diseases
but it can also protect us against some
forms of cancer and then when the immune
system is not working we may get various
types of inflammatory diseases we now
know that diseases such as type 1
diabetes as inflammatory bowel diseases
rheumatoid arthritis as multiple
sclerosis relates to inappropriate
function of the immune system so you are
hoping that in the future we can get
some medicine or some form of cure that
will serve slow down our own immune
system and don't attack us our own
system so to speak okay the beauty where
the discoveries made by this year's
lauritz is the fact that they have
discovered molecules and cells which can
be manipulated just with that purpose to
slow down
or when he did enhance immune responses
and there's another very important
aspect of this is that is of course
vaccines and there being a lot about the
discussion about vaccines but we also
have heard about the bird flu and what
was different dangers got what would
bearing do the discoveries have on this
field well these discoveries first of
all explain to us how vaccines work
that's tremendously important they open
up for the generation of new types of
vaccines hopefully better vaccines so
they have a very close bearing to
vaccine generation could you develop
that better I've scenes involves about
dance pets better vaccines could be
vaccines that are stronger problem with
some of the vaccines today is that they
elicit responses but too weak responses
we now have tools to make vaccines
eliciting stronger responses so that
more people who get vaccinated get
protected from the disease's we
vaccinate against there is a debate in
the Western world at least about the
benefits of accidents I mean a lot of
people are scared these days to get
their children vaccinated and so on what
do you have for missing what you have
them what a message do you have for them
well it's very sad in a way strange
discussion that is going on and vaccines
only in the last centuries saved more
than 400 million lives that is more than
10 x 10 times as many people as died in
any war during the 20th century to me
this is striking information certainly
vaccines have done so much good for
Humanity so much better than it has done
bad things what do you think personally
is the most exciting thing about this
those discoveries that got the prize
today but they tell us how we can make
vaccines better they provide tools for
us to make new drugs to be able to
modulate the immune response
is in various disease settings where
immune action is working or not working
another scare of course is the
resistance to antibiotics will these
discoveries help in any way to develop
more smarter antibiotics maybe not
directly but indirectly I think they
will do its of course important for us
to understand how our immune system
works it has the present like the
present discoveries perhaps have greater
impact for vaccine development than
antibiotics per se let's turn for a
second for now the big disease that we
are all scared of the cancer what how do
this immune system work against or with
cancer well the immune system has the
capacity to recognize certain types of
cancer our hope is of course that we in
situations where patients have cancer
should be able to enhance to create new
drugs that would enhance the immune
response in such a way that the immune
cells would attack cancers but cancers
are difficult to handle because they
also have their own ways to evade the
immune recognition so it's really a
battle going on in our bodies cancer
changed all the time and the immune
system is trying to develop to get to it
yeah exactly and this is the struggle we
have to work with this is a common
misunderstanding because people lay
people who are usually talk about
medicine and say hey we can go to the
moon but you can't cure cancer is how
difficult can it be it's certainly very
difficult relatively speaking it was
probably quite easy to go to the moon we
still don't know how to cure all cancers
but we have become better and we are
becoming better and better for every
year how these three gentlemen the old
gentleman of course they have sort of
found the two lines of Defense's you
said earlier in our in our body systems
how they collaborated in this how they
met in conferences or have they done
their work separately I'm absolutely
convinced that all of them have met at
conferences at several different
occasions but they
I've been working on three different
research lines they have not been
colleagues to the best of my knowledge
that colleagues in the sense of working
together shrill hoffman had a long
interest in the immune response of fruit
flies to infectious agents Bruce boiler
had an interest in studying how mice
defend themselves against certain types
of bacteria and Rolf Steinman had an
interest in that the dit excels he
discovered and really worked out how
they work okay if you now finally would
have a wish it will be there again like
10 years from now what new discoveries
have been made in this field certainly
knew when better vaccines is hope for
the future and I think we will be there
you